Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to
Deeeep.io... the game about the ocean where there are sharks and fishes and seagulls
And I'm not sure what else but it's a multiplayer game in the .io style
And hopefully it's not going to make me scream like a little baby (Oh Mark you know it will). Oh, I didn't want to spect - oh, I'm a ghost fish
Ohhhhhh OHH ooooooooh....
All right, we're gonna play this... choose your animal. Oh, ugh!
Is that a worm?!?! I'll be this guy what I- Oh you're a deep sea creature. Going up causes strange things to your body. That sounds great
Why wouldn't I want that a... grown boy? you know what i-
Whoa? Hey buddy those look dangerous. Let's go trace the- oh OH Ahhhh
Nutritious!! Oh this is the good shit right here
Oh what am I now you give back part of the damage you see?
What did I turn into? some kind of other- I'm a king crab. OOH. I- they know me! They know
AAHHH
It's a shark... whoa!
Ok that was scary! Okay, well at least I'm not dead... he missed.
Thankfully he's too stupid know where I am
Pressure pushing, pushing in on me...pushing out on me? Oh give me all that good shit.
Oh, I'm a JELLYFISH now.
Get poisoned bitches! If you want some and you know it, touch my tentacle.
Oh what am I? I'm a squid? Hello!
Don't be hurt for three seconds and stay still to hide
I don't know how to stay still. This - this train don't have no brakes. HI, Spongebob!
When did you die and get- AHH! It's a big squuooood!!!
Okay, I'm fine then. Let me hoover up these glow balls. MMM, tasty delicious glow balls~!
There's a LOT of 'em, yummy yummy, oh boy!
EEEHHHNNN
well, that was fun while it lasted. Too late now, no more.
OOH! keep close to the top when you're about to evolve.
You're, you're assuming a lot about my survival rate here... Which I don't think I'm gonna survive very hard
Oh, that's a submarine and THAT'S A BIG SQUID... I'm a bird AHHH
(screaming inaudible words)
ITS DRAGGING ME DOWN TO THE BOTTOM SO I DIE IM NOT- AAAUUGH IM BEING FEASTED UPON
You fucking asshole king crabs
Squid bitches I got squidded
Mmm lets try this again. Oh, I'm a jellyfish, okay alright, they left me with a little bit. That's nice wow
Oh, what? Ah, there we go. I'm a squid boy.
Excuse me. You don't want none of this look at my sick maneuvers. Oh, you think you can outmaneuver me
I'm a squid of the sea you gotta get to the surface
You know about to evolve you wouldn't know much about that excuse you excuse you I'm a bird now. (Singing) I'm gonna fly in
the sky oh
Boy those look tasty
Apparently not. I'm just flying around (End of marvelous singing voice)
Oh, hi, okay. Woah, wait. Whoa whoa what the hell was that? I'm pooping. Which is awfully nice
Don't know why I'm pooping but okay. Excuse you. Agh, I got a dive for my food. What kind of bullshit
Oh, hey he's - AAAH don't, don't - NOOOO
Noooo I hit a sea otter!
Started from the bottom and now we're back at the fucking bottom again. Oh God damn it
I just I just got squidded! Aah you speared me with your dick tip? Oh my God. There's so much here. Oh my God
It's a Bonanza. Oh it's a Bon - . Oh I'm about to be Bonanza'd
Yee, yee, yee, yee
Yee
Yee..
AGH he found me! Oh, no there's so many threats. I'm a bird again I'm a  bird again. I'm bird again
Oh boy, that don't look good
Ok I'm a seagull that crab went flying. I don't know why. Oh hello your - you shouldn't be up here
You shouldn't be up here. Give me - Oh yeah. Oh, you shouldn't be up here either. Welcome to my beach.
Oh, I get it. I'm supposed to eat these things and not - Ohh okay goodbye.
I don't know why these animals that shouldn't be flying are flying but they are.
YEEESH. I don't know why there's a sea otter just gettin' up in there.. Ah get - come here, you
I want you, UGGH - Got ya.
That's too bad for you. I'm poisoned, but I probably shouldn't have done that, seems to have been detrimental(?), oh
I shouldn't be down here. Okay, gonna be down here. Oh no, NOO!
No, I was about to evooolve!!
I was about to shed my skin and lurch forward in my new form oh
Such an asshole, such an asshole. Okay I gotta start going up, here we go now.
Bloop, bloop - I'm a bird now
I shouldn't be down here - Oh boy, gotta go gotta go, 'scuUUUse me
Hah, pooped on that sea otter, haa get some. And by get some i meant get some of my poop. Oww you
fucking asshole get out of here you otter bitch. (Murmuring unintelligable things related to murder) Yeah you want some of this? Yeeah
Aghh no not again! It's the same one
Agh, that was scary, I thought I was gonna die for sure.
Okay, but I don't know what that was, but it flew by and I don't know. Ugh, yeah. Get some. You want some?
I got more if you want some, got a lot of it in a surplus supply, got it it Costco
I got a lot of some want to get it get it off me
You know what, it's a burden of this much some you know you got
Golf load where you can diversify your assets whenever you got a lot of some so if you want some?
Kind of ring my phone up and get my pager down. You know give me good if you want it
I'll give it to you for a discount if you want it like in garage sales. If you're into that sort of thing
I know I am. I don't know about you, I don't live your life man, but if you want some come get it
Lot of it. Oh, what am I next?! I don't know what - Ooh, this is..
You can also eat flappy ducks. How do I do that? How do I - I'm a ray.
Whoo oh flappy ducks., I think I got one - I think. So that's what was oh
That's what was getting those oh. I am trapped help help please. Oh God - Thank you
I mean, you didn't help me at all. I helped myself. it was all more like -
Oh you were there, and I didn't die. So, thank you?
No! No! No! Yes? Yes!
Yes, oh, God. I'm being chased again - oHH it's a land, thing?
I'm dead I'm dead I'm - Ohh, how 'bout you don't?
I persuaded him with my charm, and you want some oh
Double meat in my body!~ (wtf)
Oh whoops. Sorry. Oh, you trying to hide in there? Oh, well. I guess that worked I guess. I didn't getcha.
Good, can't complain. Job's good, life is good. Just sucking up balls in the bottom of the ocean. Not a bad life - WOAAAAAAHHHH!
You know, I like to scream at random. It's pretty good for my lungs - AAAAA
I GOT STUUCK, NOOOO
HELP MEE, I'M BEING ATTACKED -
OOohh, YES!
It somehow worked out for me. I don't know how, but it did. I'm just trying to get by. Oh boy.
I don't know what the hell that was - NOOOO
I've been pierced! Agghhh, you -
I, just get - Thank you for distracting him! Well that didn't , that almost was bad. I'm an otter though.
Wow, that was a chain of events that I would have never anticipated. Oh I'm a beaver!
I'm not an otter, I'm a beaver
Stupid me!
Who'da thought - Ah! Hey you want fight? I can fight you I could fight you, but I'm not gonna fight you, but I could! Ow, ow - Gotcha
You're in my paw
You're in my paw, come with me! I'm bringing this guy with me. Oh, he's a parasite, no! He's on me. Oh, that makes sense
I think. I've no idea what makes sense.
Is he gonna come bursting out of my chest later once I give him enough food? Am I already dead? Is that how this works?
Oh God - Oh, hello, excuse me. Excuse you. Nyoom. BOY that's a lot of flaps.
I get some flaps. Oh, I love this flappy combo shit. Doosh! Oh, gimme that - Oh,
Yeah, that's good shit.
Well, that's the good shit. I lost my passenger, but you know. Hey, you know easy come easy. Go. Pick these, thank you. Whoa. That's dangerous AAAGH
You missed me see? I scream as a natural defense. Really gets me going.
Not like in a sexual way. Yep, turtles isn't spelled the end for me. I'm gonna die. I don't have any  juice. God
That was not as nearly as fast as I was hoping but it
You know, it did the trick. Got away pretty good. Hey, crab, you wanna get eat?
Yeah, you don't, that's right. Live and learn, and then get loves and get the fuck outta my neighborhood.
Oh, you came back huh you - I'm gonna be this guy. Oh
I'm a mimic! Don't know what that means, but
Cool
Cool, I think
Yeah, I'm a mimic
Cool
Got it. Nice.
Oh, no! Get blinded! You're blind, you're blind. Oh boy, oh boy, oh boy,
Oh boy that guy's mean. Oh, he's very mean. Oh God, he's mean, he still wants me.
Good to know that I'm still attractive, but don't do that. You want some? Ooh skoosh, gotcha. Ha! I'm a crab now, but I'm not really.
Anybody wanna try and get the 'crab'?
Ah he got fooled! He was fooled by me! I'm the fooler! He got fooled all over himself! Ha!
The Mimic works, apparently, I didn't know if it would or not but apparently it works. Ow, ow, huh-huh
You thought you were bumping up against a sqood?! Not quite. Oh get -
All kinds of wrecked! Ahhhhh
No one can stop me. No one can stop me. I'm not what I seem to be. Not what I seem to be.
AHH! I'M WHA - Ohhh, NOOO!!
Okay, anyway, I lost. I did pretty good though. That was a fun one. That was legitimately a fun one.
I liked that a lot. So, uh, like I said before there's a ton of these ".io" games on this website
There's just tons and tons. They make a whole mess of these, but this was a lot of fun.
So thank you everybody so much for watching if you want to play these games
I'll put them in the link in the description below if you want to play any more of these games
Or you want me to play let me know which one of these are good and I'll play them. They're really fun, so
Thank you everybody so much for watching and as always. I will see you in the next video. Buh - Bye!